Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. A slight clinking behind me made me turn my head. Six black men advanced in a file, toiling up the path. They walked erect and slow, balancing small baskets full of earth on their heads, and the clink kept time with their footsteps. I could see every rib, the joints of their limbs were like knots in a rope, each had an iron collar on his neck, and all were connected together with a chain whose bites swung between them, rhythmically clinking. All their meager breasts panted together, the violently dilated nostrils quivered, the eyes stared stonily
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。身后传来的一声轻微的叮当声，让我转过了头。六名黑人男子排成一纵队，艰难地沿着小径前行。他们昂首挺胸，步履缓慢，头上顶着装满泥土的小篮子，叮当声与他们的脚步声合着拍子。我能看到每一根肋骨，他们的四肢关节就像绳子上的结，每个人脖子上都戴着一个铁领圈，所有人之间都用一条链子连着，链子的咬合处在他们之间晃荡，发出有节奏的叮当声。他们所有消瘦的胸膛一起起伏，剧烈扩张的鼻孔在颤动，双眼呆滞地盯着
uphill. They passed me within six inches without a glance with that complete death-like indifference of unhappy savages. Behind this raw matter one of the reclaimed, the product of the new forces at work, strolled despondently, carrying a rifle by its middle. He had a uniform jacket with one button off, and seeing a white man on the path, hoisted his weapon to his shoulder with alacrity. This was simple prudence, white men being so much alike at a distance that he could not tell who I might be. He was speedily reassured, and with a large white, rascally grin and a glance at his charge,
上坡。他们从我身旁六英寸处走过，连看都没看我一眼，带着那种不幸的野蛮人特有的、彻底的死一般冷漠。在这群生手后面，一个被改造过的人、新作用力下的产物，正沮丧地漫步着，手里横扛着一支步枪。他穿着一件少了一颗扣子的制服上衣，看到小径上有个白人，便敏捷地把武器扛到肩上。这纯粹是出于谨慎，因为白人在远处看起来都差不多，他猜不出我是谁。他很快就放心了，脸上带着一个白人无赖般的咧嘴大笑，瞥了一眼他的看押对象，
seemed to take me into partnership in his exalted trust. After all, I also was a part of the great cause of these high and just proceedings. Joseph Conrad, of course, writing in Heart of Darkness, which he wrote in 1899. And he sat down to write that nine years after he himself had visited the Congo Free State as a merchant seaman, captaining a steamer, the roade belge, the king of the Belgians, up the Congo deep into the interior, just as Marlow in Heart of Darkness will do. And Marlow is describing their experiences that Conrad himself, we know, definitely had. He saw scenes like that, preparatory to taking the steamer up the river to meet the mysterious and enigmatic, charismatic Mr. Kurtz. And what he's seeing, of course, is a chain gang
似乎把我当成了他在崇高信托中的合伙人。毕竟，我也是这些崇高而正义的行动的伟大事业的一部分。约瑟夫·康拉德，当然是在《黑暗的心》中这样写的，这部作品写于1899年。他坐下来写下这些，是在他自己作为一名商船船长访问刚果自由邦九年之后，当时他驾驶着一艘轮船“罗阿德·白利基”（roade belge），即比利时国王的船，沿着刚果河深入内陆，就像《黑暗的心》中的马洛将要做的那样。马洛正在描述的经历，正是我们所知道的康拉德亲身经历过的。他见过那样的场景，那是他驾船逆流而上、去会见那个神秘、莫测且极具个人魅力的库尔茨先生之前的准备工作。而他所看到的，当然是一支劳工链队
of porters escorted by an armed African officer building the railway that will facilitate Leopold II's control of this vast expanse of the Congo that he's been given at a conference in Berlin where no Africans were in attendance. And Conrad, when he went to the Congo, initially was a true believer. He trusted the philanthropic intentions of Leopold II, but by the time he left, he had a very, very different perspective. And you know, the last line, Dominic, of that passage that we read, I also was a part of the great cause of these high and just proceedings. I mean, a deep and painful sense of irony there. Very definitely self accusatory. Absolutely. A very self lacerating irony there, the high
在一名武装非洲军官的护送下，修建铁路，这将促进利奥波德二世对刚果这片广袤土地的控制，这片土地是他在柏林会议上被授予的，而那次会议没有一个非洲人出席。康拉德去刚果时，最初是个虔诚的信徒。他相信利奥波德二世的慈善意图，但当他离开时，他的视角发生了非常非常大的变化。你知道的，多米尼克，我们读的那段话的最后一句，我也曾是这些崇高而正义的行动的伟大事业的一部分。我的意思是，里面有一种深沉而痛苦的讽刺感。绝对是对自身的谴责。毫无疑问，里面有一种深刻的自我鞭笞式的讽刺，“崇高而正义的行动”。今天的节目将是一个相当黑暗的主题。因此，我们将探讨利奥波德国王统治下刚果自由邦的现实。我的意思是，多米尼克，为了强调这一点，你在上一期节目中说过，这堪与20世纪的巨大暴行相比。所以我们应该警告大家，这里面有很多很多的恐怖之处。确实如此。在我们深入探讨这些之前，让我们回想一下上期节目发生了什么。核心人物是比利时国王利奥波德二世，这个孤独、笨拙、自私、冷酷的男人，我们在那一期节目中将他比作你，汤姆。他开辟了自己的私人殖民领地，占领了中非的一大片土地，
and just proceedings. And today's episode will be quite a dark subject. So we're going to get into the realities of the Congo Free State under the regime of King Leopold. I mean, Dominic, just to emphasise, you said in the previous episode that this bears comparison with the great atrocities of the 20th century. So we should warn people that there are a lot of, a lot of horrors in this. There are indeed. Before we get into them, let's remind ourselves what happened last time. Central character was King Leopold, the second king of the Belgians, this lonely, awkward, selfish, ruthless man, whom we likened in that episode, Tom, to you. And he has carved out his own private colonial fiefdom, a huge chunk of central Africa with
刚果河在其心脏地带蜿蜒流淌，那里可能生活着800万到1200万人。他的代理人、特工亨利·莫顿·斯坦利——这位伟大的探险家，尽管也是双手沾满鲜血的探险家——与450个不同的定居点签署了条约，将他们的土地、经济权利，最重要的是他们的劳动力，交给了刚果国际协会，而这后来被证明是自1885年5月起建立的刚果自由邦的幌子。在整个过程中，利奥波德向世界，特别是向欧洲其他政府保证，他的动机是慈善的。甚至在六年后的六年里，他还对比利时首相说，刚果国绝对不是一桩生意。
the Congo snaking through his heart, somewhere between 8 and 12 million people maybe living there. His agent, his operative Henry Morton Stanley, the great explorer, though bloodstained explorer, has signed treaties with 450 different settlements, giving their land, their economic rights and crucially their labour to the International Association of the Congo, which has proved to be a front for the Congo Free State, which has been set up from May 1885. In all this process, Leopold has assured the world, and in particular, the other governments of Europe, that his motives are philanthropic. Even six years later, he told the Belgian Prime Minister, the Congo state is certainly not a business.
如果它在某些土地上收集象牙，那也只是为了减少赤字。换句话说，我们之所以支付这么多的钱，是因为我们太致力于我们所承诺的慈善文明使命，以至于我们需要收集一点象牙来收支相抵。值得非常坦率地说，这完全是谎言。从一开始，利奥波德真正关心的，我认为只有一件事，那就是将他的利润最大化。而这的证明就是他在刚果自由邦存在的头一天所做的事情。因此，在1885年5月29日，即它被宣告成立的那天，他发布了一项法令，规定所有无主土地现在都属于国家，也就是属于他。但因为
If it gathers ivory on certain of its lands, that is only to lessen its deficit. In other words, we're paying out so much money because we're so committed to the philanthropic civilizing mission that we promised that we need to gather a little bit of ivory to make ends meet. This, it is worth saying very starkly, is completely untrue. From the very beginning, Leopold is really interested, I think, only in one thing, and that is maximizing his profits. And the proof of that is what he does on the very first day of the Congo Free State's existence. So on the 29th of May, 1885, the day that it is proclaimed, he issues a decree that all vacant land now belongs to the state, i.e. to him. But because
“无主”这个词没有被定义，什么是无主土地？在刚果这样的世界里，这到底意味着什么？当地人并不一定像比利时人那样具有相同的财产权概念，这实际上意味着刚果的整片土地……在哪个法庭？刚果大概没有法庭吧？利奥波德正在践踏这一切。我的意思是，这是什么？这旨在给欧洲的什么人留下深刻印象？这项法令。是的。这项法令，是向刚果的特工发出的一道命令。这并不是说他在向他的官员下达命令。
the word vacant is not defined, what is vacant land What does that mean in in a world like the Congo where? The the locals don't necessarily have the same concept of property rights as Belgians do that Effectively means the entire land of the Congo in what court presumably there are no courts in the Congo Leopold is failing all this. I mean, what is this? Who is this designed to impress people back in Europe? The decree. Yeah. The decree is, it's an order being sent out to operatives in the Congo. It's not a question of, he's issuing orders to his officials.
事情就是这样运作的。但他给它披上了法律术语的外衣。是的。以防外人闯入。正如他对那些条约所做的那样，对吧？他需要有一些东西向其他欧洲人展示。如果有人问起，正如我们将在下周发现的那样，当人们开始询问时，他需要有一条纸面记录可以展示，以证明这一切完全是公开合法的。
That's how it works. But he's kind of garbing it in legalese. Yes. Just in case outsiders might intrude. As he has done with the treaties, right? He needs to have something to show the other European. If anyone asks, as we will discover in next week, when people do start to ask, he needs to have a paper trail that he can show to say, I'm doing it all completely above board.
现在发生的情况是，刚果自由邦的领土——记住，是比利时国土的67倍，相当于英国、西班牙、意大利、法国和德国加起来的大小——被分割成巨大的领土，作为特许权授予私营公司。现在，这些公司大多由比利时股东拥有，但在大多数情况下，至少50%的股份属于利奥波德国王本人. 换句话说，即使在他分发了特许权、而且不是刚果自由邦自己在运营这片领土的情况下，他也将获得最大份额的利润。不仅如此，当这些公司缴纳税款或通行费时，他们是直接交给他的。
So what now happens is that the territory of the Congo Free State, remember, 67 times the size of Belgium, the size of Britain, Spain, Italy, France and Germany put together, this is carved up into gigantic territories which are awarded as concessions to private companies. Now most of these companies are owned by Belgian shareholders but in most cases at least 50% of the shares belong to King Leopold himself. In other words, even where he's handed out concessions, and it's not the Congo Free State running the territory itself, he is going to get the lion's share of the profits. And what is more, when those companies pay tax or they pay tolls, they pay it to him.
所以无论你从哪个角度看，他都是赢家。那么，自由邦将如何运作呢？它与其他欧洲殖民地略有不同，因为它拥有的基础设施少得可怜。所以如果你想想同一时期的印度，英国有一个印度的文官服务系统。成千上万的人申请。有考试。这是一个备受追捧、声望极高的职位，成千上万的人被派去担任类似地区专员和官员之类的工作。
So he wins everywhere you look at it. So how is the Free state going to work? It is slightly different from other European columnists because it has a tiny, tiny infrastructure. So if you think about India in the same period, there was an Indian civil service in Britain. Thousands of people applied to it. There were exams. It was very sought after, prestigious, and thousands of people were sent out to work as kind of district commissioners and officials and all
而且这一切都非常明显，是什么就是什么。非常公开。印度是一个高度互联的国家。现在那里有铁路以及所有这类东西。所以人们可以看到正在发生的事情。确实如此。那里有报纸，有实地的人员，印度人中也有识英文的人。是的，当然。所以人们知道发生了什么，但在刚果并非如此。刚果并非如此，而且人数要少得多。因此，在刚果自由邦成立五年后，在刚果工作的欧洲人仍然不到500人，他们是商人、士兵、传教士、官员等等。其中最大的一个群体——不超过80人——驻扎在这个新首都，
of this kind of thing. And it's all very obvious what it is. It's very public. And India is a very connected country. It's got the railroads now and all that kind of stuff. So people can see what is going on. Exactly. And there are newspapers and there are people on the spot and there are people literate in English among the Indians. Yes, of course. So people know what's going on but that's not the case in the Congo. It's not the case in the Congo and the numbers are far, far smaller. So after five years of the Congo Free State's existence, there are still fewer than 500 Europeans working in the Congo as traders, soldiers, missionaries, officials and so on. The biggest of these groups, and it's no more than 80 people, are based in this new capital,
也就是博马港。这差不多就是斯坦利完成其著名的穿越非洲腹地徒步之旅的终点。所以在博马，他们修建了码头、仓库，有一家酒店，一个军事基地，有一家酒店，一个军事基地，一家医院，一个邮局等等。总督就驻扎在那里，但总督实际上只是一个傀儡。我们不会提到任何总督，因为他们并不重要。所有的决定都是在布鲁塞尔由一小内阁官员做出的，他们只对利奥波德负责。
which is the port of Boma. That's pretty much where Stanley had finished his famous trek across the heart of Africa. And so in Boma, they have built docks, they've built warehouses, there's a hotel, there's a military base, there's a hotel, there's a military base, there's a hospital, there's a post office and so on. The governor general is based there, but the governor general really is a cipher. We won't be mentioning any governors general because they're not important. All the decisions are made in Brussels by a tiny cabinet of officials who are answerable to Leopold.
所以实际上，他统治着刚果。我在笔记里写过他是一个专制君主，但那并不是完全正确的术语。事实上，正确的术语是一个所有者。他是刚果的主人，他以董事会主席的身份管理着它。他拥有最终决定权。至于刚果的其他白人，他们沿着河流呈一线排开，分布在一系列这种权宜之计的据点里。通常这些据点不过是几间茅草屋和一些装着刚果自由邦国旗（带有金色流苏的蓝旗）的堡垒。
So in effect, he rules the Congo. I've written in the notes an absolute monarch, but that's not quite the right term. Actually, the right term is a proprietor. He is the owner of the Congo and he runs it as the chairman of the board. He has the final decision. As for the other white men in the Congo, they are strung out along the river in a line of these kind of makeshift stations. So often these stations are no more than a handful of thatched huts and kind of block houses with the flag of the Congo Free State, the blue flag with the gold staff.
而康拉德小说中的库尔茨先生就驻扎在其中一个据点里。没错，就在内陆心脏地带的内部据点。如果你被派往那里，如果你去到那里，你就会有仆人。你的合同规定你每天可以喝一瓶酒，你的合同还向你保证定期从英国供应橘子果酱，从丹麦供应黄油，还有鹅肝——这会吸引空中航线生产者，还有罐头肉等等。但不管——这会吸引空中航线生产者，还有罐头肉等等。
And it's in one of these stations that Mr. Kurtz in Conrad's novella is based. Exactly, the inner station right in the heart of the interior. Now, if you are sent out there, if you go out there, you will have servants. Your contract stipulates that you can have a bottle of wine a day and your contract also promises you a regular supply of marmalade from England, Dutta from Denmark, foie gras, which would appeal to the airware producer, canned meat and so on and so forth. But whether, which would appeal to the air producer, canned meat and so on and so forth.
但这些男人们是否能定期获得这些物资，当然是另一回事了，因为这取决于汽船。几乎所有去那里的人都是单身，他们带妻子的非常罕见。大多数人都与当地女性同居。而且他们不一定是比利时人，对吧？事实上，大多数都不是比利时人。不，大多数都不是比利时人，正如我们在上一期节目中所说的那样，大多数比利时人对拥有殖民地并不感兴趣。你知道的，他们不是，他们不是。
But whether or not the men get these supplies regularly is of course a very different matter because it depends on the steamboats. Almost all of the men who go are single, very uncommon for them to take wives. Most of them take up with local women. And they're not necessarily Belgian, are they? In fact, most of them aren't Belgian. No, most of them are not Belgian because as we said in the last episode, most Belgians are not interested in having a colony. You know, they are, they're not.
具有帝国心态的人。不，他们也不是特别热衷于航海的人。所以那种登上一艘船然后出海的想法，你知道的，比利时在这个时候实际上并没有商船队。嗯，这很有趣，不是吗？《黑暗的心》中的库尔茨先生，康拉德明确指出他是英法结合部的产物，整个欧洲都参与塑造了他。
Imperially minded people. No, and they're not particularly maritime people either. So the idea of, of getting on a ship and going out, you know, Belgium doesn't really have a merchant Navy at this point. Well, it's interesting, isn't it? That Mr. Kurtz in Heart of Darkness, Conrad specifies that he's the son of an Anglo-French union and that all of Europe went into making him.
他不是比利时人，那就是库尔茨先生。在为刚果自由邦工作的人中，有一个群体代表性极高，那就是有从军经历的人。正如我们将看到的，这说明了一切。所以这些家伙有两样其他欧洲人没有的东西。因为可能听了上一期节目的人会好奇，如果其他欧洲人觉得这如此困难并且没有去刚果，这些家伙有什么？他们有两样东西。
He's not Belgian, that's Mr. Kurtz. The one group that is very heavily represented among the people who work for the Congo Free States is people who have been in the military. And that, as we will see, tells its own story. So these guys have two things that other Europeans don't have. Cause people maybe who listened to the last episode may be wondering if other Europeans found this so difficult and didn't go up the Congo, what do these chaps have? They have two things.
第一，他们有自动机枪。所以马克沁机枪，那是第一种自动连发枪，发明于1884年。那是斯坦利为利奥波德完成所有条约的那一年。所以无论发生什么，我们有马克沁机枪，而他们没有。正是如此。第二件事是现代医学。所以过去逆刚果河而上总是会让人送命的威胁是你会死于疾病。1881年，科学家证明黄蚊子会传播黄热病，所以人们现在旅行时都带着蚊帐。他们还随身携带大量金鸡纳霜
One, they have automatic machine guns. So the Maxim gun, which was the first automatic repeating gun was invented in 1884. That was the year that Stanley completed all the treatises for Leopold. So whatever happens, we've got the Maxim gun and they have not. Exactly. And the second thing is modern medicine. So the thing that was always poppable off going up the Congo was the threat that you would die of disease. In 1881, scientists have proved that yellow fever was carried by mosquitoes, so people are now traveling with mosquito nets. And they're also traveling with enormous quantities of quinine
来对抗疟疾，这些是从荷属东印度群岛的种植园进口的，这是世界全球化的一个迹象。当然。而且他们还有汽船。我的意思是，那是另一个需要强调的关键点。没有汽船，就没有殖民地。我认为这样说并不过分。是的，因为他们无法进入内陆。刚果人称这些船为“在水上行走的房子”。他们确实这么叫。话虽如此，死亡率其实仍然相当高。
to fight malaria, which they have imported from plantations in the Dutch East Indies, sign of the globalization of the world. Of course. And also they've got steamboats. I mean, that's the other crucial thing to emphasize. No steamboats, no colony. I think that's fair to say. Yeah, because they couldn't get into the interior. The house that walks on water, the Congolese call these boats. They did indeed. All of that said, the death rate is still actually quite high.
所以问题是，你到底为什么要去看？我认为答案是，刚果对那些可能会去克朗代克或南非兰德、或者实际上可能会加入法国外籍军团之类的人有着吸引力。嗯，因为欧洲处于和平时期，不是吗？而且是一种资产阶级的、隐隐有些无聊的和平时期。是的。
So the question is, why on earth would you go? And I think the answer is that the Congo appeals to the kind of people who might otherwise have gone to the Klondike or to the Rand in South Africa, or indeed might have joined the French Foreign Legion or something like that. Well, because Europe is a piece, isn't it? And it's the kind of bourgeois, faintly boring piece. Yes.
所以如果你想要冒险，这将是完美的。正是如此。因此，亚当·霍赫希尔德在他那本我们经常提到的精彩著作《利奥波德国王的鬼魂》中说，一个在欧洲注定要过着小镇银行职员或水管工生活的人，可以转而成为一个军阀、一个象牙商人、一个大型猎物猎人和一个后宫拥有者。他引用了一名比利时军官在1894年写给家人的精彩信件。万岁，刚果！这家伙说，没有什么能与之相比。我们拥有自由、独立和视野广阔的生活。在这里你是自由的，而不是社会的单纯奴隶。在这里
So if you want adventure, this would be perfect. Exactly so. So Adam Hochstrahlt in his brilliant book, King Leopold's Ghost, that we've mentioned quite a lot, he says, someone fated for life as a small town bank clerk or a plumber in Europe could instead become a warlord, an ivory merchant, a big game hunter and a possessor of a harem. And he quotes a brilliant letter from a Belgian officer to his family in 1894. Vive le Congo, says this guy, there is nothing like it. We have liberty, independence and life with wide horizons. Here you are free and not a mere slave of society. Here
一个人就是一切。战士、外交官、商人。为什么不呢？但正如我们将看到的，这种自由感是建立在他人奴役之上的。确实如此。他用了“商人”这个词，那个比利时军官。当然，隐藏在这背后以及整个项目背后的，就是一个简单的词：象牙。这就是他们来这里的目的。获取象牙易如反掌。你只需开枪打死一头大象，然后割下它的象牙。
one is everything. Warrior, diplomat, trader. Why not? But that sense of freedom is, as we will see, founded on the servitude of others. Exactly it is. He uses the word trader, that Belgian officer. And of course what lies behind that and what lies behind the entire project is the single word ivory. That is what they are here for. Getting ivory is dead easy. You just shoot and kill an elephant and then rip out its tusks.
困难的部分是将象牙运出刚果。因此，利奥波德目前完全依赖汽船，但在急流周围有大约200英里的路段无法使用汽船。所以在这里你必须走陆路。理想情况下，你需要的不是一队队气喘吁吁地上下小径的背夫，你想要一条铁路。是的，当然。因此，到1887年，他有一支测量员团队正在绘制
The hard part is getting the ivory out of the Congo. So Leopold so far is relying entirely on steamboats, but there is that 200 mile section around the rapids where you can't use the steamboat. So here you have to go over land. And ideally what you need is not team supporters trudging up and down the trail, you want a railway. Yeah, of course. So by 1887, he has a team of surveyors sketching
绕过急流的路线，这将需要很长时间。他们实际上直到1890年才开始铺设轨道，因为地形太艰难，存在疾病威胁等等。所以现在，他不得不依靠数以万因此，正如我们在引言中所讨论的，数以万计的背夫。再说一次，这难道不是一种，我的意思是，一个巨大的骗局吗？基本上，这些人的奴役——正如我们在康拉德的开篇片段中听到那样被锁起来——被这样辩解：好吧，他们需要这样做，这样我们才能拥有铁路，这样我们就再也不需要背夫了。
a route around the rapids, and it will take a very long time. They don't actually start laying tracks until 1890, because the terrain is so difficult because of the threat of disease and so on. So for now, he has to rely on tens of thousands of porters, hence what we talked about in the introduction. Again, isn't that kind of, I mean, a tremendous scam that the basically the servitude of these people, you know, chained up as we heard in that kind of opening passage from Conrad, is justified by saying, well, they need to do it so that we can have the railways so that we won't need porters.
是的，完全正确。他们在为了自己的利益修建铁路。这是一种进步式的苦役。是的。因为一旦我们建成了铁路，他们就会过上美好的生活，因为将不再有背夫了。这基本上就是逻辑。这就是借口。当然他们运送的东西，他们运送汽船，但是
Yes, exactly. They're building a railway in their own interests. It's kind of progressive hard labor. Yeah. Because once we finished the railway, they'll have a brilliant life because there won't be porters anymore. That's basically the logic. That's the justification. And of course what they're carrying, they're carrying the steamboats, but
他们还运送橘子果酱、鹅肝、步枪、机枪弹药，所有这些东西。他们没有报酬，因为根据刚果自由邦的法律，非洲人没有钱。不允许非洲人拥有金钱。所以他们通常是用黄铜支付，有时用布匹，但都是这种黄铜棒，这是一种奇怪的权宜之计的货币。我们已经引用过《黑暗的心》，但我们不需要通过虚构来了解他们是如何被对待的。自由邦的一位官员在他的回忆录中——这段引文太像康拉德的引文了，真是非同寻常——写道：“一队被铁链锁住脖子的可怜鬼，把我的行李箱和盒子搬向
they're also carrying the marmalade, the foie gras, the rifles, machine gun ammunition, all of this stuff. They're not paid because under the Congo free states laws, there is no money for Africans. Africans are not allowed money. So they are being paid generally in brass, sometimes in cloth, but in these kind of brass rods, which is a kind of strange makeshift currency. And we've quoted from Heart of Darkness already, but we don't need to go to fiction to know how they're treated. A Free State official in his memoirs, and this is a quotation that's so like Conrad's quotation, it's extraordinary, a file of poor devils chained by the neck carried my trunks and boxes towards
码头。”他说，有一百个人，颤抖着，充满恐惧，监工拿着鞭子走在旁边。对于每一个墩实宽背的家伙，有多少人是像木乃伊一样干瘪的骷髅，皮肤磨损，布满深深的疤痕，身上覆盖着化脓的伤口。然后他说，再次带着一种苦涩的讽刺，“没关系，他们都很胜任这份工作。”然后，一位比利时参议员在1896年进行了访问。同样，他说：“我们所到之处，不断地遇到这些背夫，黑皮肤，痛苦不堪，只穿着一条极其肮脏的遮阴布，头发蓬乱，光着头，支撑着负荷。他们成千上万地这样来来往往，被国家征用，装备着国家
the dock. He says there are a hundred of them trembling and fearful, the overseer walking by with his whip. For each stocky and broad-backed fellow, how many were skeletons dried up like mummies, their skin worn out, seamed with deep scars, covered with separating wounds. And then he says, again with a kind of bitter irony, no matter, they were all up to the job. And then a Belgian senator visited in 1896. Again, he says, everywhere we went, unceasingly we meet these porters, black, miserable, with only a horribly filthy loincloth, frizzy and barehead, supporting the load. They come and go like this by the thousand, requisitioned by the state, armed with its
强大的民兵，由那些视他们为奴隶并携带着他们薪水逃跑的首领们交出来，满身尘土和汗水，虫子般在山谷间蔓延，做着西西弗斯的任务，死在路边或旅程的终点，在他们的村庄里因过度劳累而死去。”所以这并不是一份完全积极的报告，对吧？不，不，这是这个比利时人的一份非常批判性的报告。但实际上还有更糟糕的要来，因为第一段引文中，自由邦官员提到了一位挥舞着鞭子的监工。而这根鞭子成为了利奥波德国王模范殖民地在海外的至高象征，因为这是一根被称为“希科特”（chicot）的鞭子。
powerful militia, handed over by chiefs whose slaves they are and who make off with their salaries, dusty and sweaty, insects spreading out across the mountains and valleys, their task of Sisyphus, dying alongside the road or the journey over, heading off to die from overwork in their villages." So that's not an entirely positive report, is it? No, no, that's a very critical report by this Belgian guy. But there's actually worse to come because that first quotation, the Free State official mentioned an overseer twirling a whip. And this whip becomes the supreme symbol abroad of King Leopold's model colony, because this is a whip called the chicot.
这基本上是一条在太阳下晒干的河马皮带。它有一个非常锋利的边缘，对吧？是的。所以它会打破皮肤。挨上25下你就会晕过去。挨上100下几乎肯定会丧命。有各种各样的记录来自那些看到利奥波德的士兵、他的执行者鞭打年仅七八岁儿童的人。
And it's basically a strip of hippopotamus hide that's been dried in the sun. It has a very sharp edge, doesn't it? Yeah. So it breaks the skin. 25 strokes of that you will pass out. 100 strokes of that will almost certainly kill you. And there are all kinds of accounts from people who see Leopold's soldiers, his enforcers, flogging children who are sometimes as young as seven or eight.
有一位名叫斯坦尼斯拉斯·勒弗朗克（Stanislas Lefranc）的官员，是一名比利时地方法官，他抵达了刚果。他看到这些男孩被鞭打。这些就像是八岁的男孩。原因在于他们在官员面前都笑了。他非常生气。他命令他的手下鞭打镇上的每个男孩，每个仆人男孩，50鞭。所以这非常像，呃，波兰村庄里那个带有小学生的党卫军军官。是的，确实如此。
There's an official called Stanislas Lefranc, a Belgian magistrate, who arrived in the Congo. He saw these boys being flogged. These are like eight-year-old boys. And the reason is that they had all laughed in the presence of an official. And he was so cross. He told his men to flog every boy, every servant boy in the town, 50 lashes. So that's very like the, um, the SS officer in the Polish village with the school boys. Yes, it is.
鞭打他们。是的。而勒弗朗克进行了投诉，这被制止了。但后来，勒弗朗克被他的上级叫去，他们对他说：“不要再这么做了，因为这会破坏纪律。我们需要这个镇上的纪律。”而且大多数欧洲人似乎只是认为使用“希科特”是理所当然的。他们自己并不挥舞它，而是让非洲人代劳。嗯，他们让那些挨过鞭子的人去行军礼，对吧？他们必须站起来行军礼。
Flogging them. Yeah. And Lefronc complained and it was stopped. But afterwards, Lefranc was called in by his superiors and they said to him, don't do that again, because that undermines discipline. We need discipline in this town. And most Europeans just seem to have taken the use of the chicote for granted. They don't wield it themselves. They get Africans to do it for them. Well, they get people who've been flogged to kind of give a salute, don't they? They have to stand up and give the salute.
当然，你必须这么做。所以这些执行者，这是一支名为“公共武力”（Force Publique）的私人军队。我的意思是，这是一个绝对可怕的组织。到19世纪90年代中期，里面大约有19,000人。它是中非最大的军队，这是一支由一小群白人军官组成、而士兵全部是非洲黑人的私人军队。军官往往是比利时人。普通士兵最初是来自西非或桑给巴尔的雇佣兵，但随着时间推移，他们被来自刚果的被征召入伍者所取代。
Absolutely, you do. So the enforcers, this is a private army called the Force Publique. I mean, an absolutely terrifying organisation. By the mid 1890s, there were about 19,000 men in it. It's the biggest army in Central Africa, and it's a private army with a small group of white officers and the men are all black Africans. The officers tend to be Belgian. The ordinary soldiers initially, they are mercenaries from West Africa or from Zanzibar, but over time they're replaced with conscripts from the Congo.
我说的是被征召入伍者，但有一种观点认为，这些实际上是奴隶士兵。比利时档案中有各种各样的证据，显示有关于锁链的订单等等，这些锁链是用来把内陆的年轻男子或男孩带到公共武力中工作的。我们知道，代理人为他们为公共武力提供的男子数量领取奖金。其中一些人会从友好的部落首领那里购买十几岁的男孩。这些十几岁的男孩，当他们可能被戴上铁链、带到军营时，被告知他们必须参军。他们将服役七年。他们受到极其糟糕的对待。
I say conscripts, but there is an argument these are effectively slave soldiers. There's all kinds of evidence in the Belgian files of orders for chains and things, chains required to bring young men or boys from the interior to work in the force public. We know that agents were paid a bonus for how many men they provided for the force public. Some of them would buy teenage boys from friendly chiefs. And these teenage boys, when they were maybe chained, led to a barracks, told they had to join the army. They would serve a seven year term. They were incredibly badly treated.
我的意思是，他们自己也遭到“希科特”的鞭打，他们花了大量时间在内部争斗，基本上是在平息哗变。所以在《利奥波德国王的鬼魂》这本书中，有大量关于这些可怕、血腥的哗变的叙事，当时公共武力的部下调转枪口对准了他们的军官，然后必须调来其他部队来对付他们。如果他们没有在平息哗变，他们就是在与叛军作战。因为我们上次说过刚果的种族分裂有多么严重。他们与叛军作战，因为我们上次说过刚果在种族上是多么碎片化。在比利时人到达之前，它有着长期的种族暴力历史，这种历史
I mean, they themselves are flogged with a chicot and they spend an awful lot of time fighting among themselves, basically fighting mutinies. So in the book, King Leopold's Ghost, there are long narratives of kind of these hideous, bloody mutinies where forced public units have turned against their officers and then other units have to be brought in to deal with them. And if they're not fighting mutinies, they're fighting rebels. Because we said last time how ethnically fragmented the Congo is. they're fighting rebels because we said last time how ethnically fragmented the Congo is. It has a long history of ethnic violence before the Belgians ever arrived, a history that
从未真正消失。你可以认为，公共武力以及实际上整个自由邦，只是在一片不断变幻的竞争和联盟世界中扮演了一个新的、致命的玩家。这就像征服者出现并将自己卷入墨西哥的政治中一样。正是如此。但我的意思是，恐怖程度超出了图表。刚果以前从未有过类似的事情。不，我的意思是，这些战役、叛乱以及游击战和反叛乱行动可以持续10年、20年。它们涉及——我的意思是，当弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉将《黑暗的心》改编为《现代启示录》时
never really goes away. And you could argue that the force public and indeed the free state generally is just a new player in an endlessly, a new and deadly player in an endlessly shifting world of kind of rivalries and alliances. So this would be like the conquistadors turning up and kind of embroiling themselves in the politics of Mexico. Exactly. But I mean, the horror is off the scale. There's nothing ever been like anything like this in the Congo. No, I mean, these campaigns, these rebellions and kind of guerrilla campaigns and counterinsurgency operations can last for 10, 20 years. And they involve, I mean, when Francis Ford Coppola turned Heart of Darkness into Apocalypse
现在，这其中有真正的逻辑，因为实际上这些反叛乱行动看起来非常像越南战争。村庄被烧为平地，平民被围捕并谋杀，妇女被强奸，儿童被奴役。这是一种可怕、可怕的场景。但不同之处在于，现场没有记者，没有摄像机，没有任何东西来记录这一点。它发生在一个，我想你可以说是一种黑暗中。确实如此。现在，听这个节目的一些人可能会说，你们呈现了一幅非常非常黑暗的画面。你们显然读过这本书，它对刚果的生活描绘了一幅非常黯淡的画面，有没有更积极的一面呢？下周，我们将为我们的“历史俱乐部”成员制作一期加更节目，讨论亚当·霍赫希尔德这本书的批评者，以及那些说“哦，其实故事还有另一面”的人，但关于这一点只有一个说明，利奥波德当然承诺了
Now, there was a real logic to that because actually these counterinsurgency campaigns look very much like the Vietnam War. Villages being burned to the ground, civilians being rounded up and murdered, women being raped, children being enslaved. It's kind of hideous, hideous scenes. But the difference is that there are no journalists on the spot, there are no cameras, there's nothing to record this. It is happening I suppose in a kind of darkness you would say. It is indeed. Now some people listen to this may say you're presenting a very, very dark picture. You've obviously read this, this book that presents a very bleak picture of life in
文明使命，但公平地说，实际上几乎没有证据表明这一点——例如，没有由国家资助的非洲儿童学校。有一些宗教基金会，但根本没有试图建立国家教育基础设施。然而，他确实有儿童之家，被称为“儿童殖民地”，但它们的目的是仅仅为公共武力提供新兵。因此，世界被告知这些是没有父母的儿童孤儿院，但通常这些是在反叛乱行动中被杀死的人的幸存儿童，被拖进这些可怕的强行军中，
the Congo, is there a more positive side? Next week, we'll do a bonus episode for our Restless History Club members talking about the critics of, of the Adam Horschel's book and people who have said, oh, there's actually another side to the story but just one note on this leopold of course promise. A civilizing mission but it's fair to say there's actually very little evidence of that so there are no state funded schools for african children for example there are some religious foundations but there's no attempt whatsoever to set up a state educational infrastructure. He does, however, have children's homes, which are called children's colonies, but the point of them is merely to provide recruits for the force public. So the world is told that these are orphanages for children with no parents, but often these are the surviving children of people who have been killed in the kind of counterinsurgency operations and dragged back in these hideous forced marches in
其中可能三分之一的儿童会死去，然后他们被关进这些儿童之家，那里的纪律是通过铁链和“希科特”来强制执行的。这些家园里大约有一半的儿童死亡。如果你活了下来，你就会反过来加入公共武力。所以这个循环仍在继续。组织这一切的人对此有什么感觉？大体上他们对此感觉很好。他们对自己的所作所为没有任何道德上的内疚。嗯，当然有些人有。我们将谈到这一点。我的意思是，康拉德确实很有名。
which maybe a third of the children will die and then they're put in these children's homes where discipline is enforced by with the chain and with the chicot. About half of the children in these homes die. And if you live, you then join the force public in your turn. So the cycle continues. How are the people who are organizing this feeling about this? They feel great about it by and large. They have no moral qualms about what they're doing. Well, some do, of course. And we'll get on to this. I mean, Conrad does famously.
是的，但康拉德，我们下周将制作一期关于《黑暗的心》的节目，届时我们会谈到这一点。我的意思是，康拉德确实很有名。是的。但康拉德，我们下周将制作一期关于《黑暗的心》的节目，其中我们将讨论康拉德在踏上归途的旅程中，他是如何给朋友和亲戚写信的。他说，你知道，没有人，没有人跟我说话。每个人都恨我。我非常孤立。每个人都认为我很可憎。一个明显的解释是，他表现出了他对
Yes, but Conrad, we will do an episode on Heart of Darkness next week, in which we'll get onto this. I mean, Conrad does famously. Yes. But Conrad, we will do an episode on Heart of Darkness next week in which we'll discuss how when Conrad went on his journey on the way back, he's, he writes letters home to friends and relatives. And he says, you know, nobody, nobody talks to me. Everybody hates me. I'm very isolated. Everybody regards me as repugnant. And an obvious explanation for this is that he has shown his shock at
他所见之事的震惊和厌恶。而其他人则说他是不健全的。他是不可信的。他不是我们这群人中的一员。因为他从中出来时受到了绝对的创伤，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，基本上，他像爬回伦敦一样，根本无法谈论他所看到的事情。真的。但我简直不敢相信没有其他人……
what he sees and his disgust. And other people say he's, he is unsound. He's not to be trusted. He's not one of us. Because he comes out of that absolutely traumatized, doesn't he? Yeah. I mean, he basically, he kind of crawls back to London and just can't talk about what he's seen. Right. But I can't believe about what he's seen. Right. But I can't believe that there aren't other people who...
还有其他人。我提到了那个地方法官勒弗朗克，他说“停止鞭打男孩”，然后因此受到训斥，被告知“你在破坏纪律”。所以确实有这样的人。但是出去杀死那些你随后将他们奴役的男孩的父母，我的意思是，这是一种，我的意思是，敢问一句，这叫邪恶吗？你说话的口气就像是一个对历史一无所知的人。我的意思是，人们经常这样表现。我知道类似的事情也曾发生过，例如在征服墨西哥的过程中，
There are other people. I mentioned that magistrate, Lefranc, who said, stop flogging the boys and is then told off for it and said, you're undermining discipline. So there are such people. But going out and killing the parents of boys who you then enslave, I mean, that's a kind of, I mean, dare one say, evil? You're speaking as somebody who's then enslave. I mean, that's a kind of, I mean, dare one say evil. You're speaking as somebody who's unaware of history. I mean, people often behave like this. I'm aware that similar things happened in, for instance, in the conquest of Mexico,
但有西班牙神甫在反对它。你知道的，这些探险活动中存在着良知的呼声。确实有良知的呼声，我们下周会谈到一些。我们会谈到那些为反对利奥波德国王的运动提供信息的人。但他们似乎往往是传教士，嗯，我们会谈到这一点。我的意思是，有很多传教士并不是为比利时国家工作的。我只是在特别思考那些主持这个可怕系统的军官。军人，他们完全赞成。我的意思是，有很多关于军人的记载说：“刚果其实太棒了。
but there are Spanish priests who are opposing it. You know, there are voices of conscience in these expeditions. There are voices of conscience conscience and we will come to some next week. We will come to the people who give information to the campaigns against King Leopold. But they often seem to be missionaries and well we'll come to that. I mean there are a lot of missionaries who are not working for the Belgian state. I'm just thinking particularly about the officers who are presiding over this horrific system. The military men, they're all for it. I mean, there are lots of accounts of military men who say, the Congo is actually brilliant.
你可以随心所欲。这比呆在欧洲家里好得多。你可以做一个大人物。你可以做一个——还记得那句话吗？如果你愿意，你可以成为一个军阀。”我认为事情的真相是，我们讨论的不是庞大数量的人。记住最多500人。大体上，如果你去了，并且呆了几个星期以上，你就已经签约加入了这个项目。
You can do what you like. It's much better than being at home in Europe. You can be a big man. You can be a, remember that quote? You can be a warlord if you want. I think that the truth of the matter is we're not talking about huge quantities of men. Remember 500 maximum. By and large, if you go and if you stay more than a few weeks, you're signed up to the project.
如果你不喜欢它，如果你不喜欢那个项目，我会说你马上就回家。你会找个理由离开。但如果你去了，你就会非常快地变得麻木。我的意思是，这有点像在问，1941年的德军军官是如何为他们的所作所为辩解的？他们找到了这样做的方法。这是一个巨大的问题。
If you don't like it, you go home straight away if you don't like that project, I would say. You find a reason to get out. But if you go, you become desensitized very quickly. I mean, it's rather like asking how did We you know, Wehrmacht officers justify what they're doing in 1941? They find the way of doing it. That is a huge question.
但你看，我认为这不是一个很难回答的问题，因为我认为人类在历史中经常那样表现，因为我对人性的看法非常黯淡。这对我来说不是一个谜，因为我只是看到它一次又一次地重演。我每次读到关于比利时军官的记载时总是感到惊讶——我们已经讨论过比利时不是一个具有帝国心态的国家——他们中似乎很少有人有任何良心不安。你可以说我们有两样东西。我的意思是，有一种帝国主义心态，当然还有一种种族主义心态。所以他们并不认为非洲人是和他们一样的人，他们相信他们
But you see, I don't think that's a very hard question to answer because I think human beings often behave like that in history because I have a very bleak view of human nature. It's not a puzzle to me because I just see it recur again and again. I'm always surprised reading accounts of the Belgian officers and we've talked about how Belgium is not an empirically minded nation, how few of them seem to have had any qualms at all. You can argue that there are two things we have. I mean, there's an imperialistic mentality and there's of course a racist mentality. So they don't regard the Africans as people like themselves and they believe they
有权按照自己的选择对待他们。我想这也是自我选择的结果，也许，你知道的，你正深入丛林之中。如果你是一个有点，如果你有一颗悲天悯人的心，你不会去刚果当雇佣兵，我认为这样说并不过分。是的，但是悲天悯人和悲天悯人是不同的。我仍然觉得令人震惊的是，这些军官中似乎很少有人说：“哦，我对这件事不太确定。”
have a right to treat them as they choose. I suppose also it's self-selecting that perhaps, you know, you're going out in the middle of the jungle. You don't go to the Congo to work as a mercenary if you're a kind of, if you've got a bleeding heart, I think it's fair to say. Yeah, but there are bleeding hearts and there are bleeding hearts. I still think it is striking how few of these officers seem to have said, oh, I'm not sure about this.
但我觉得这说明了一切。我的意思是，关键在于他们是自我选择的，他们的偏见、文化包袱的分量意味着他们可能倾向于认为这是可以接受的。这也正是《黑暗的心》所探讨的内容。所以，我们会谈到这一点。但在我们休息之前，在这期节目中我们完全漏掉了一件事，那就是非洲人的声音。
But I think that tells its own story. I mean, that's the thing that they're self-selecting and the weight of their prejudices, their cultural baggage means that they are perhaps predisposed to think it's okay. It's also kind of what Heart of Darkness is about. That, so we will come to that. But just before we go to the break, there's one thing that we've completely missed in this episode, and that is an African voice.
事实是，这些声音真的很难找到，因为正如我们之前所说，人们并没有把事情写下来。我们确实通过采访收集到了一些零碎的资料。这里有一个很好的例子，它也回答了你的问题。曾有一个自由邦的特工，我想他是美国出生的，名叫埃德加·卡尼修斯（Edgar Canisius）。后来，他基本上背叛了自由邦，并向反对它的活动人士提供了大量信息。他收集了人们的故事。其中一个是来自刚果东部的名叫伊兰加（Ilanga）的妇女，她曾被公共武力绑架。她把自己的故事讲给卡尼修斯听，他将其复述了下来。
And the truth is, they are really hard to come by, because as we said before, people aren't writing things down. We do get fragmentary sources collected in interviews. So here's a really good example that also answers your question. There was a Free State agent who I think was American born called Edgar Canisius. And later on, he ends up basically turning against the Free State and giving a lot of information to campaigners against it. And he collected stories from people. And one of them is a woman called Ilanga from the east of Congo, who had been kidnapped by the Force public. And she told her story to Canisius and he repeated it.
他确信她在说实话，因为他也遇到了绑架她的人。所以他说，当她告诉我发生了什么事时，我相信她。在我们休息之前，我只读一段摘选，让大家感受一下当时在实地的真实情况。所以这是一位名叫伊兰加的妇女。她说：“我们都在田里忙碌时，一个信使来到村里，说有一大群人正在过来，许多白人也和他们在一起。三四个人来到我们家，抓住了我。还有我的丈夫阿利卡和我的姐姐卡蒂加。我们被拖进了
He was convinced that she was telling the truth because he also met the men who had kidnapped her. So he said, I believe her when she's telling me what happened. I'll just read an extract before we go to the break to give you people a sense of what this was like on the ground. So this is a Alanga. She says, we're all busy in the fields when a runner came to the village saying that a large band of men was coming and that many white men were with them. Three or four came to our house and caught hold of me. Also my husband Alika and my sister Katinga. We were dragged into
他深信她在说实话，因为他也遇到了绑架她的那些人。所以他说：“我相信她告诉我的经历。”在休息之前，我先读一段摘录，让大家感受一下当地的真实情况。这是阿兰加（Alanga）的话。她说：“我们当时都在地里忙活，一个信使跑来村里说，有一大群人正朝这边走来，其中有许多白人。三四个人来到我家，抓住了我。还有我的丈夫阿利卡（Alika）和我的妹妹卡廷加（Katinga）。我们被拖进
the road and tied together with cords about our necks. We were all crying. For now we knew that we were to be taken away to be slaves. We set off marching very quickly. My sister Katinga had her baby in her arms, but my husband Alika was made to carry a goat. We had nothing to eat, for the soldiers would give us nothing. On the fifth day the soldiers took my sister's baby and threw it in the grass, leaving it to die, and made her carry some cooking pots. On the sixth day we became very weak from lack of food and from constant marching and my husband who marched behind us with the goat sat down beside the path and refused to walk more. The soldiers beat him but still he refused to move. Then one of them struck him on the head with the end of his gun and he fell upon the ground. One of the soldiers caught the
道路，脖子上套着绳子。我们都在哭泣。因为现在我们知道我们要被带去当奴隶了。我们开始快速行军。我的妹妹卡蒂娜怀里抱着婴儿，而我的丈夫阿利卡则被迫背着一只山羊。我们没有什么可吃的，因为士兵什么也不会给我们。第五天，士兵抢走了我妹妹的婴儿，把它扔在草丛中，任由其死去，并逼她背着一些炊具。第六天，由于缺粮和连续行军，我们变得非常虚弱，我的丈夫扛着山羊走在我们后面，他在小路旁坐了下来，拒绝再走一步。士兵们殴打他，但他仍然拒绝挪动。然后其中一人用枪托猛击他的头部，他倒在地上。其中一个士兵抓住
goat while two or three others stuck the long knives they put on the end of their guns into my husband. I saw the blood spurt out and then saw him no more, for we passed over the brow of a hill and he was out of sight." So that Dominic is the reality of what Marlow called the high and just proceedings of King Leopold's Congolese fiefdom. So that was the reality of what Marlow called the high and just proceedings of King Leopold's Congo and a sombre moment, Dominic, on which I think we should go and take a break. Black shapes crouched, lay, sat between the trees leaning against the trunks, clinging to the earth half coming out, half effaced within the dim light, in all the attitudes
山羊，另外两三个人把他们枪头上的长刀刺进我丈夫的身体里。我看到鲜血喷涌而出，然后就再也看不到他了，因为我们翻过了一个山丘，他已经消失在视线之外了。" 多米尼克，这就是马洛夫所说的那场由利奥波德国王统治的刚果领地内 "高尚而正义的审判" 的现实。多米尼克，这就是马洛夫所说的那场由利奥波德国王统治的刚果内 "高尚而正义的审判" 的现实，这是一个沉重的时刻，我想我们该去休息一下了。黑色的人影蜷缩着，躺着，坐在树木之间，靠着树干，紧贴着大地，半边隐现，半边在昏暗的光线中消逝，带着种种
of pain, abandonment and despair. They were dying slowly, it was very clear. They were not enemies, they were not criminals, they were nothing earthly now, nothing but black shadows of disease and starvation, lying confusedly in the greenish gloom. Brought from all the recesses of the coast in all the legality of time contracts, lost in uncongenial surroundings, fed on unfamiliar food, they sickened, became inefficient, and were then allowed to crawl away and rest. So Conrad again, in Heart of Darkness 1899, and his narrator
痛苦、被遗弃和绝望的姿态。很明显，他们正在慢慢死去。他们不是敌人，他们不是罪犯，他们现在已经不属于尘世间，除了疾病和饥荒的黑色阴影外，什么也不是，杂乱无章地躺在微绿的阴暗之中。他们在各类定期合同的合法性庇护下，从海岸的各个角落被带到这里，迷失在格格不入的环境中，吃着不熟悉的食物，他们生病了，变得无所作为，然后就被允许爬开去休息。康拉德在 1899 年的小说《黑暗的心》中再次这样写道，他的叙述者
Marlowe has arrived in the Congo and is climbing up the hills that lead to the Congo that is navigable. And he is witnessing workers who are building the railway that will expedite European access to the highlands and he is not exaggerating there, is he? I mean, there were hundreds, thousands of people who died during the construction of that railway. That's absolutely right.
马洛夫已经抵达刚果，正顺着山路向上攀爬，通往可以通航的刚果河。他亲眼目睹了工人们正在修建铁路，这条铁路将加速欧洲人进入高地，他在这一点上并没有夸张，对吧？我的意思是，在那条铁路的建设过程中，有成百上千的人死亡。完全正确。
And we'll get onto the railway and the people who died working on it a little bit later, but to go back, Conrad made his journey up the Congo in 1890. And it was about this point that this terrible story entered a new chapter that was even darker than before. And this new period, this terrible period in the Congo's history, traces its origin, not to Belgium actually, but to Belfast in Northern Ireland. So in October 1887, an inventor called John Dunlop had attached a pneumatic
我们稍后会聊到铁路以及在修建铁路时丧生的人，但回过头来看，康拉德是在 1890 年沿着刚果河展开他的旅程的。正是在这个时候，这个可怕的故事翻开了新的一页，比以往更加黑暗。刚果历史上这段崭新的、可怕的时期，其根源其实并不在比利时，而是在北爱尔兰的贝尔法斯特。因此，在 1887 年 10 月，一位名叫约翰·邓ロップ的发明家将一条充气
rubber tire to his son's tricycle as an experiment to see if this would work. And within three years, the Dunlop company were making tires commercially. And from that point onwards, there's a huge bicycle craze, a bicycle boom with these rubber pneumatic tires. I mean, people have been familiar with rubber for a while, haven't they? Cause it's, um, is it end of the 18th century that it gets its English name because somebody notices that you can use rubber to rub things out. Yeah.
橡胶轮胎装在他儿子的三轮车上，作为实验，看看这是否行得通。在三年之内，邓禄普公司就开始商业化生产轮胎了。从那时起，由于这些橡胶充气轮胎的出现，掀起了一股巨大的自行车热潮，即自行车大繁荣。我的意思是，人们对橡胶并不陌生，对吧？因为，嗯，是在 18 世纪末，它才有了英文名字，因为有人注意到你可以用橡胶来擦除东西。对。
I think something like that. I mean, people have known about it certainly for decades, but it's only in this point in the early 1890s, the worldwide rubber boom really gets underway. And I guess it's because people need rubber insulation for the new telephone, for telegraphs, for electrical wiring, so electrification promotes rubber, the enthusiasm for rubber in bicycles, but also it's used in tubes and in factories and all these kinds of things. So it's the great more of industry.
我想差不多是这样。我的意思是，人们当然已经了解它几十年了，但正是在 1890 年代初的这个节点上，全球范围内的橡胶大繁荣才真正拉开帷幕。我想这是因为人们需要为新型电话、电报、电线提供橡胶绝缘材料，所以电气化促进了橡胶的发展，人们对自行车橡胶的热情高涨，而且它还被用于管道、工厂以及所有这些类型的东西。所以它是工业的巨大推动力。
Absolutely. Now, where do you get rubber? You can get wild rubber or you can get plantation rubber. In the Congo, in the forests of the Congo, rubber vines are very plentiful. The costs, as with ivory, are very low. You don't need to cultivate it, you don't need fertilizers, you don't need equipment, you just need people to go and collect the rubber and I'll explain how they do that in a second. So for Leopold, this is amazing. A rubber boom has started and as luck would have it, he has one of the world's great supplies of rubber. But he knows he's only got a limited window in which to do this because investors were already pouring money into plantations of rubber trees in Asia and in South America and rubber trees are much easier to tap than rubber vines.
绝对没错。现在，你在哪里能弄到橡胶？你可以弄到野生橡胶，也可以弄到种植园橡胶。在刚果，在刚果的森林里，橡胶藤随处可见。和象牙一样，成本非常低。你不需要去种植它，你不需要化肥，你不需要设备，你只需要人们去收集橡胶，我一会儿就会解释他们是怎么做到的。所以对利奥波德来说，这太棒了。橡胶繁荣开始了，幸运的是，他拥有世界上最主要的橡胶供应地之一。但他知道他的时间窗口有限，因为投资者已经将资金倾注到亚洲和南美洲的橡胶树种植园中，而且橡胶树比橡胶藤更容易割胶。
And that will give him what, about 20 years? He's got 20 years to tap the rubber vines in the Congo before these trees become as it were operational. And also his investments in the Congo, I mean, he's quite heavily in debt, isn't he? So he needs to leverage his assets urgently if the whole thing isn't just going to come crashing down around his ears. Absolutely right. Now, how do you get the rubber? Here's the catch. Wild rubber comes from these gigantic vines that wind their way around these trees. And these vines can
那会给他带来大约多少年的时间？他在刚果有 20 年的时间来割取橡胶藤，然后这些树木就会投入使用。而且他在刚果的投资，我的意思是，他负债累累，不是吗？因此，如果整件事情不至于彻底崩溃，他需要紧急变现他的资产。完全正确。现在，你如何获取橡胶？问题就在这里。野生橡胶来自这些巨大的藤蔓，它们缠绕在这些树木周围。而这些藤蔓可以
grow so high, 100 feet high, they go up to the sunlight. And then once they're there, they'll sort of corkscrew for hundreds more feet through the kind of jungle canopy, the forest canopy. And to get the rubber out of the vine, you basically have to slash the vine with a knife, and then you hung a pot or a bucket to collect this kind of milk, the sap that comes from the vine.
长得非常高，高达 100 英尺，它们向上延伸去追逐阳光。一旦到了那里，它们就会像开瓶器一样，在丛林树冠、森林树冠中盘旋几百英尺。要想从藤蔓中提取橡胶，你基本上必须用刀砍开藤蔓，然后挂上一个罐子或桶来收集这种乳状液，即从藤蔓中流出的树液。
Now the downside of doing that in the Congo is when you go into the forest, a lot of it is, is swamp. So it's kind of flooded, you're wading through it and you're surrounded by snakes, crocodiles and all this kind of thing. So it's, it's a, it's a health and safety nightmare. I think it's fair to say Tom. Now, once you've got the sap, the milky stuff, you need to dry it. You want it to coagulate into the rubber.
现在，在刚果这样做的一个缺点是，当你进入森林时，很大一部分都是沼泽。所以它有点被淹了，你得蹚水而过，周围都是蛇、鳄鱼以及所有这些乱七八糟的东西。所以，这是一个健康和安全的噩梦，托姆，这样说应该很公平。现在，一旦你得到了树液，那种乳白色的东西，你需要把它弄干。你想让它凝固成橡胶。
So what a lot of gatherers would do is they would get it, they'd cut the vine, the stuff comes out, then they spread it. I know this sounds really weird. They spread it on their own body. They wait till it's dried and then they kind of rip it off their body. Imagine how painful that is. Bits of hair in it. And then they put it into baskets and carry it with the baskets on their heads.
所以很多采集者会做的是，他们把它弄下来，砍断藤蔓，东西流出来，然后他们把它摊开。我知道这听起来真的很奇怪。他们把它涂在自己的身体上。他们等它变干，然后把它从身体上撕下来。想象一下那有多痛。里面还有头发碎屑。然后他们把它放进篮子里，把篮子顶在头上运走。
They will walk for tens and tens of miles down to the river to the nearest European agency. And here the rubber will be again left out to dry and then it will be loaded onto barges for the coast. So as all of that makes clear, it's quite an operation for the person who's actually gathering the rubber. I mean, you don't want to be eaten by a crocodile. Yeah. It's not a great job, is it? No, it's not something you choose to do. It's quite an operation for the person who's actually gathering the rubber. I mean, you don't want to be eaten by a crocodile. Yeah. It's not a great job, is it? No, it's not something you choose to do. It's podcasting is a better career choice.
他们会步行数十甚至上百英里，走到河边最近的欧洲代理处。在这里，橡胶将再次被放在外面晾干，然后装上驳船运往海岸。正如所有这些所清楚表明的那样，对于真正采集橡胶的人来说，这是一项相当浩大的工程。我的意思是，你可不想被鳄鱼吃掉。是的。这不是一份好工作，对吧？不，这不是你主动选择去干的事。对于真正采集橡胶的人来说，这是一项相当浩大的工程。我的意思是，你可不想被鳄鱼吃掉。是的。这不是一份好工作，对吧？不，这不是你主动选择去干的事。做播客是更好的职业选择。
I think it's fair to say basically nobody wants to do it. The only way you'll get people to do it is to force them to do it. Yeah. So there's, there's an official isn't there who says the native doesn't like making rubber, he must be compelled to do it. And there you have it. So this is where the force public, the sort of mercenary force, the private army of King Leopold and the various militias that have been enlisted by the
我想可以公平地说，基本上没有人愿意做这件事。你能让人去做的唯一办法就是强迫他们去做。是的。所以有一个官员，对吧，他说当地人不喜欢生产橡胶，必须强迫他们去做。事情就是这样。所以这就是公安部队（force publique）、那种雇佣兵力量、利奥波德国王的私人军队以及特许公司招募的各种民兵发挥作用的地方，他们的工作是把人们抓起来，让他们去弄这些橡胶。我们从一位英国副领事在 1899 年撰写的这份报告中知道了他们是怎么做的。他说，一个军官告诉我他们是怎么做的。他们走进一个村庄，居民全都逃跑了，他们开始掠夺村庄，那些进去的雇佣兵，然后他们抓住村里的妇女，追赶她们，抓住妇女并把她们作为人质，直到男人们去
concession companies, where they come in, their job is to get round people up and get them to go and get this rubber. And we know how they did it from the British vice consul who wrote this report in 1899. And he said, an officer told me what they do. They go into a village, the inhabitants all run away, they start looting the village, the sort of mercenaries who've gone in, then they seize the women of the village, they chase them, they seize the women and they keep them as hostages until the men have gone
弄够了橡胶。然后当男人们弄到了橡胶，他们就把妇女卖回给男人们，接着他们又转移到下一个村庄。所以她们基本上就是人质。这是系统性的、蓄意的、有计划地劫持人质。在刚果自由邦发给各种公司代理的手册中，有关于劫持人质的最佳方式的说明。他们用 "人质" 这个词吗？代理的手册中，有关于劫持人质斑斑的说明，有关于劫持人质的最佳方式的指令。他们用 "人质" 这个词吗？
and got enough rubber. And then when the men have got the rubber, they sell the women back to the men and then they move on to the next village. So they're basically hostages. It's the systematic, deliberate planned taking of hostages in the manual that was given to Congo Free State from the kind of company agents, there are instructions about the best way to take hostages. Do they use the word hostage? agents, there are instructions about the best way to take hostages. Do they use the word hostage?
不，他们不用 "人质" 这个词。他们说这是一种讨价还价的方式，这是一种很好的谈判方式，诸如此类。所以同样地，他们是在给出指示，他们基本上是在说去劫持人质，但他们仍然用一种可能不会敲响太多警钟的语言来包装它。但我们知道几乎每个人都这么做。我的意思是，我们知道纳粹也这么做过。人们使用法律化的语言来掩盖可怕的事情。他们几乎是自动地、本能地这样做。当然。我接受这一点。但我的意思是，利奥波德仍然把自己伪装成人道主义者。
No, they don't use the word hostage. They say it's a way of bargaining, it's a good way of negotiating, all this kind of thing. So again, they're giving instructions, they're saying basically go and take hostages, but they're still dressing it up in language that might not ring too many alarm bells. But we know that almost everybody does that. I mean, we know that the Nazis did that. People use legalistic language to disguise terrible things. They do it almost automatically, instinctively. Sure. I accept that. But I mean, Leopold is still passing himself off as a humanitarian.
我的意思是，纳粹并没有把自己伪装成人道主义者。所以我想这其中还是有一点区别的。我想也是。真让人吃惊，他们竟然能够把这种矛盾圆过去：是的，去抓人质，同时又把它包装成一种能让利奥波德看起来是个绝顶聪明、只关心给黑暗带来光明的人的方式。他们可不希望这本手册落入坏人之手。没错。
I mean, the Nazis are not passing themselves off as humanitarian. So there's a bit of a difference there, I think. I suppose so. It is kind of striking that they are able to square the circle of, yeah, go and get hostages while simultaneously framing it in a way that makes Leopold look a brilliant guy who cares only for bringing enlightenment to the darkness. They don't want this manual to kind of fall into the wrong hands. Exactly.
所以基本上你抓了人质，然后你会说，哦，看，我们每两周需要四公斤橡胶。当你完成配额时，你知道的，你就可以把人质领回去了。人们收集橡胶有报酬吗？一些首领得到的是珠子或盐的报酬。一些首领得到的是奴隶的报酬。我们知道，在 1901 年，一个首领对一个比利时官员说，哦，是的，我得到了报酬。我被给了六个女人和两个男人，我被告知，引述一下，“我可以吃掉他们，或者杀死他们，或者随心所欲地把他们当作奴隶使用”。吃掉他们？但这正是他说的。我的意思是，也许那是比利时官员在嘲笑酋长。我们不可能知道。在刚果，食人肉并非完全不为人知，但同样，这也可能是比利时人、欧洲人强加给当地人的想象。现在在某些地区，这确实是一个警察国家。工人们离开村庄需要许可证，因为他们要完成橡胶配额。在其他地区，工人们实际上被发给带编号的金属牌，挂在脖子上。我说工人们，当然，你可能会争辩。工人们这个词用错了。他们实际上是，这是奴隶劳工。这些基本上就是奴隶项圈。奴隶项圈。我们在谈论数量庞大的人。所以有一家公司，最大的特许公司之一，英属比利时印度
So basically you take the hostages and then you would say, oh, look, we need four kilograms of rubber every two weeks. And when you hit your quota, you know, you can have your hostages back. Are people paid to collect rubber? Some chiefs are paid with beads or with salt. Some chiefs are paid with slaves. We know that in 1901, a chief told a Belgian official, he said, oh yeah, I was paid. I was given six women and two men and I was told, quote, I could eat them or kill them or use them
橡胶公司（简称 ABIR），在 1906 年的账目中，它列出了 47,000 名刚果工人——“工人”再次打上了引号——他们正在为该公司收集橡胶。同样的，这正是你所谈论的那种奇怪的事情，汤姆，他们甚至需要制作一个名单吗？你知道，他们为什么要这么做？因为他们仍然对这种形式化的法律行头深陷其中、无法自拔。我猜，他们希望相信他们所做的不是赤裸裸的剥削，而是良好的商业实践。我可以问一下其中的那个“英”字吗？
as slaves as I liked. Eat them. But that's what he said. I mean, maybe that was the Belgian being the Belgian official mocking the chief. It's impossible for us to know. Cannibalism is not totally unknown in the Congo, but equally it could be something that the Belgian, the Europeans are projecting on. Now in some areas, it really is a police state. Workers would need a permit to leave their village because they're required for the rubber quota. In other areas, workers are actually given numbered metal discs to wear around their necks. I say workers, of course, that you could argue. Workers is the wrong word. They are effectively, this is slave labor. These are slave collars, basically. Slave collars. And we are talking about enormous numbers of people. So one company, one of the biggest concession companies, the Anglo-Belgian India
是的。它曾经是一家英国公司。目前它实际上已经不再是了。没错。我认为，到 20 世纪初，它的股东几乎全部是比利时人。还有一件事，这是刚果生活中最臭名昭著的一个方面，许多听众可能都听说过。有一个人对此进行了很好的描述，你提到了传教士，一个名叫威廉·谢泼德的美国传教士。1899 年，谢泼德驻扎在位于刚果南部的开赛（Kasai）地区。
rubber company, ABIR, in 1906 in its account books, it listed 47,000 Congolese workers, workers again in inverted commas, who are collecting rubber for it. And again, that's that weird thing that you're talking about, Tom, do they even need to make a list? You know, why are they doing it? Because they're still so addicted to the kind of the formal legal paraphernalia. They want to believe that what they're doing is not naked exploitation, but is good business practice, I suppose. And can I ask about the Anglo in that?
这是一个饱受刚果自由邦忠诚派与叛军之间战斗困扰的地区。谢泼德深入森林，发现被遗弃的村庄已被烧成平地，到处都是尸体。他感到震惊，但他继续前行，来到了利奥波德忠诚派的营地，那些保持忠诚、与刚果自由邦合作的部落。当他走近时，立刻被某种东西被熏烤的气味所吸引，就像熏肉的气味一样。他说，酋长带他来到一个木制的棍棒框架下，框架下方生着火，而在框架上，在棍棒上，
Yes. It had once been a British company. It is actually no longer at this point. Right. It's shareholders, I think, are almost exclusively Belgian by the early 1900s. So there's one more thing, and this is the single most notorious aspect of life in the Congo, which many listeners may have heard of. A guy who describes this very well is, you mentioned missionaries, an American missionary called William Shepard. In 1899, Shepard was based in a region called the Kasai, which is in the south of the Congo.
在那种框架上有断手，81 只右手，人手。酋长对他说：“看，这就是我们的证据。我总是必须砍下我们杀死的人的右手，以便向国家展示我们杀死了多少人。”熏制它们的目的是为了防止它们腐烂。刚果非常炎热潮湿。所以把它们熏制意味着你可以保存它们。酋长可以把它们拿给刚果自由邦或特许公司的官员看，然后得到他的奖励。现在，这在那些撰写关于刚果历史的书籍的人当中是一个非常、非常具争议的话题。
And this was an area that was plagued by fighting between loyalists to the Congo Free State and rebels. Shepherd went deep into the forests and he found abandoned villages that had been burned to the ground and were littered with corpses. And he was horrified and he kept going and he got to the camp of Leopold's loyalists, to kind of tribes that were loyal, that had collaborated with the Congo Free State. And he was struck as he approached straight away by the smell of something being smoked, like meat being smoked. And he said the chief took him to a sort of wooden framework of sticks under which there was a fire burning and on the framework, on the sticks,
有些人说这是一种长期存在的习俗。这是一种来自非洲和阿拉伯奴隶贩子的习俗，他们一直有砍掉别人手的习惯。把这个归咎于利奥波德国王是不公平的。好吧，我的意思是，这是一种可以追溯到很久以前的习俗，我的意思是，它可以追溯到古埃及。另一些人则说，实际上发生的情况是，在自由邦统治下，其他历史学家认为，在刚果自由邦的统治下，这变得制度化了，并且以一种前所未有的方式系统化了。它几乎变成了勾选框、会计记账的一部分。它被工业化了。
on the kind of frame were hands, 81 right hands, human hands. And the chief said to him, see, here is our evidence. I always have to cut off the right hands of those we kill in order to show the state how many we have killed. And the point of smoking them was that they wouldn't rot. Congo is very hot and humid. So you smoke them means you can preserve them. The chief could show them to Congo free state or concession officials and then get his reward. Now, this is a very, very controversial subject among people who write
它被工业化了。没错。人们的一个普遍误解是，这些手是从活人身上砍下来的。这可能是因为你会看到一些活人被砍断手的照片。嗯，因为这发生在塞拉利昂，对吧？臭名昭著的塞拉利昂。
about the Congo. Some people say it's a kind of long established practice. It's a practice that comes from African and Arab slave traders who've been cutting off people's hands. And it's unfair to blame this on King Leopold. Well, I mean, it's a practice that goes back a very, I mean, it goes back to ancient Egypt. Others say actually what happens is that under the Free State, other historians under the Congo free state, this becomes institutionalized and sort of systematized in a way that it had never quite been before. That it almost, it becomes part of the box ticking, the accountancy. Becomes industrialized.
但大多数受害者已经死了。关于刚果的另一本好书是大卫·范雷布鲁克（David Van Reybrouck）写的。其中很大一部分基于口述历史。这非常清楚地表明，大多数被砍掉手的人，我的意思是，他们已经死了，他们是尸体。利奥波德本人，当他发现——我们下周会谈到——关于砍手事件的轩然大波时，他对人们因此批评他感到非常恼火。他说：“砍手？这太愚蠢了。”
It becomes industrialized. Exactly. One common misconception that people will have is that these were cut off living people. That's perhaps because they'll have, you'll have seen photos of living people whose hands have been cut off. Well, because it happened in Sierra Leone, didn't it? Notoriously.
他说：“我会砍掉他们身上的其他部位，但不是手。我在刚果唯一需要的就是人们的手来收集橡胶。”我的意思是，这让你对利奥波德的冷血 cynicism 有所体会。但我认为发生的情况是，在公安部队中，从尸体上砍下手几乎变成了一种目的本身，因为他们把手带回给他们的军官、欧洲军官，这说明，“我正在认真对待这项工作。我杀了很多很多的人。这就是证据。”并且有一种说法，而且我认为是正确的，即公安部队军官根据收到的手数量领取奖金。
But most of the victims were already dead. There's another great book on the Congo by David Van Raybroek. A lot of it based on oral history. And that makes very clear that most of the people who had their hands cut off, I mean, they're already dead, they're corpses. Leopold himself, when he found when there's a great storm, as we will come to next week about the cutting off of hands, he was very annoyed that people criticized him for it. He said, cutting off hands, that's idiotic.
所以这就像狂野西部猎取头皮一样。完全就是这样。这是一个真的非常、非常好的比喻。既然我们到了这一步，我想可以公平地说，我们在道德上确实已经深入了黑暗的核心。我的意思是，这种事情，如果你是一个敏感的听众，你可能已经停止收听了。有些作家认为其中很多内容被夸大了，被耸人听闻化了。对我来说，我的意思是，我们将在下周的特别节目中大量讨论这一点，但对我来说，我认为有太多关于欧洲官员强迫人们吃粪便、喝蓖麻油或在人们耳垂上开枪并把他们当作靶子练习等等的记录了。
He said, I'd cut off the rest of them, but not the hands. That's the one thing I need in the Congo is people's hands to collect the rubber. I mean, that gives you some sense of Leopold's cynicism. But I think what happened is that among the force public, cutting the hands off corpses does become almost an end in itself because they take them back to their officers, their European officers, and this says, I'm taking the job seriously. I've killed lots of people. Here is the evidence. And there was some suggestion, and I think it's correct, that forced public officers were paid bonuses based on how many hands.
我认为有太多的例子，不可能全都是夸大其词，甚至是捏造的。好吧，而且许多记录不都是来自于像康拉德这样的人吗？那些曾作为虔诚的信徒走进去，却对他们所看到的一切感到震惊而走出来的人；或者来自于那些认为这是利奥波德为基督之光打开刚果黑暗伟大机遇的传教士，他们同样被他们所发现的景象所创伤。我的意思是，如果事情没有发生，我看不出他们为什么要捏造这些。不，我同意。你必须相信所有这些传教士都在编造故事，
So it's like scalp hunting in the Wild West. Exactly it is. That's a really, really good comparison. Now that we're at this point, I think it's fair to say that we really are kind of morally in the heart of darkness. I mean, this is the kind of thing that really, if you're a sensitive listener, you've probably already stopped listening. There are some writers who think a lot of this has been exaggerated and sensationalized. For me, I mean, we will talk about this a lot in next week's bonus, but for me, I think there are far too many accounts of European agents forcing people to eat excrement or to drink castor oil or shooting holes in people's earlobes
而且所有这些记忆，我的意思是，有一些臭名昭著的例子。有一个叫莱昂·菲尔韦斯（Leon Fierves）的人。他收集的橡胶比任何人都多。他来自比利时瓦隆的一个农民家庭。他是赤道省的专员。我们知道他吹嘘自己的方法，他告诉手下砍掉脑袋，他，你知道的，砍掉脑袋以激发忠诚和纪律，因为人们不给他食物。他砍了一百颗脑袋。他会让人们带一篮子满满的手来。
and using them for target practice and stuff like that. I think there are far too many examples for them all to be exaggerated or indeed made up. Well, also aren't a lot of the accounts coming from either people like Conrad, people who had gone in as true believers and come out appalled by what they've seen, or by missionaries who think this is a great opportunity that Leopold has opened up the darkness of the Congo for the light of Christ, and likewise are traumatized by what they find. I mean, I don't see why they would make it up if it wasn't happening. No, I agree. I think you have to believe that all these missionaries are inventing stories,
他对此完全公开，毫不羞耻。这再次构成了库尔茨这一人物形象的一部分，因为库尔茨正是那个带回的象牙比任何人都多的人。当马洛夫逆流而上时，人们称赞他带回了最多的象牙，对于这在现实中究竟意味着什么，你其实已经有了某种直观的感受。完全正确。让我们把时钟拨到 1895 年。刚果自由邦现在正在庆祝它的十周年。利奥波德也在庆祝他的 60 岁生日。从许多方面来看，他的生活绝对是痛苦不堪的。他的妻子恨他。
and that all the memories of these, I mean, there's, there are some notorious examples. There was a guy called Leon Fierves. He collected more rubber than anybody else. He was from a farming family in Wallonia in Belgium. He was the commissioner for the Equator district. We know that he boasted about his methods, that he told his men cut off heads and he, you know, cut off heads to inspire loyalty and discipline because people weren't giving him food. He cut off a hundred heads. He would ask people to bring baskets full of hands.
她把所有的时间都花在骑马上。还有大笑。好吧，她其实再也不笑了。我想可以公平地说，欢笑已经离她而去。他的大女儿路易丝嫁给了一位德国王子，他们的婚礼如果说有什么不同的话，那就是比利奥波德的还要糟糕。她在新婚之夜试图逃跑，结果被关在疗养院里六年。所以这有点悲惨。第二个女儿斯蒂芬妮，她嫁给了奥地利的皇太子鲁道夫
He was completely open and unashamed about it. And that again is part of what Kurtz is about because Kurtz is the guy who's bringing in more ivory than anyone else. And when he is praised, you know, as Marlow is going up the river, as the guy who is bringing in more ivory, you already have a sense of what that actually means in practice. Exactly. So let's move the clock forward to 1895. So the Congo Free State is now celebrating its 10th anniversary. Leopold is also celebrating his 60th birthday. His life in many respects is absolutely miserable. His wife hates him.
，他在梅林与情妇殉情自杀。是的，所以这可不太妙。利奥波德恨他的女儿们，对吧？他人生中最大的推动力之一就是确保她们继承不到任何东西。完全没错。恨他的妻子，恨他的女儿，恨比利时和比利时人。而且他的妹妹卡洛塔还在宫里晃悠。她已经彻底疯了，因为她嫁给马克西米利安，也就是那个成为墨西哥皇帝随后被枪决的哈布斯堡王朝成员。
She spends all her time riding horses. And laughing. Well, she doesn't laugh anymore actually. Laughter has fled, I think it's fair to say. His oldest daughter Louise has married a German prince and their wedding is, if anything, even worse than Leopold's. She tried to run away on her wedding night and she ended up being locked in a nursing home for six years. So that's a bit miserable. Second daughter Stephanie, she married Crown Prince Rudolf
这会是一部精彩绝伦的戏剧——利奥波德二世的家庭生活。而且他以自己的方式也相当古怪。他非常孤独，是一个极其严重的疑病症患者。他疑病到每天必须把桌布煮沸来杀死细菌。当他外出下雨时，他会在胡子上套一个防水袋，以防止胡子被打湿，这看起来非常奇特。他为什么不把胡子刮了？好问题。我想他认为胡子是他巨大男子气概的象征。
of Austria and he killed himself at Meiling in a murder-suicide pact with his lover. Yeah, so that's not good. And Leopold hates his daughters, doesn't he? And one of the great animating ambitions of his life is to ensure they don't inherit anything. Exactly. Hates his wife, hates his daughter, hates Belgium and the Belgians. And also he's got his sister Carlotta hanging around in the palace. He's gone completely mad because she was married to Maximilian, who is the Habsburg who becomes emperor of Mexico and then gets shot.
我想他是这么认为的。他的巨大乐趣——你上周提到过其中一个——就是他每天都有一份特制的烫平的《泰晤士报》。他的另一个巨大乐趣是在纪念碑、凉亭、公园等方面花钱。高尔夫球场。高尔夫球场。他喜欢高尔夫球场。他确实喜欢高尔夫球场。他的另一个巨大乐趣是与非常年轻的女孩睡觉。所以在 1885 年，他实际上在一家英国法庭上被点名，被称为伦敦一家
It would make an amazing play, the home life of Leopold II. But also he's pretty bonkers in his own way. He's very lonely, he's a massive hypochondriac. He's such a hypochondriac that every day they have to boil the tablecloths to kill germs. And when he goes outside and it's raining, he wears a waterproof bag over his beard to stop his beard getting wet, which seems very peculiar. Why didn't he shave his beard off? Good question. I think he thinks the beard is a sign of his tremendous masculinity.
淫窟的客户，他被指控每月支付 800 英镑以获得刚刚进入青春期的女孩的供应。他是个坏人。我想我们可以得出结论，利奥波德二世国王是个非常坏的人。现在，他的所有开销，当然都反映了他从橡胶中获得的大笔收入。我们很难确切知道他从所有这些橡胶中赚了多少钱。但我提到过一家特许公司，英属比利时印度橡胶公司。他们的橡胶利润超过了 700%，在他们开始投资橡胶后的四年里，他们的股价上涨了 30 倍。
I think it's what he thinks. His great pleasures, you mentioned one of them last week, which is he has a special ironed copy of the Times every day. His other great pleasures are spending money on monuments and pavilions and parks and stuff. Golf courses. Golf courses. He loves a golf course. He does like a golf course. And his other great pleasure was sleeping with very young girls. So in 1885, he was actually named in a British court as a client of a
所以我认为可以合理推测，利奥波德赚了数千万，甚至更多，用今天的钱来算，这是一个天文数字、天文数字般的巨额财富。而且情况对他的好转才刚刚开始。到他 60 岁时，他的铁路终于接近完工了。这是一个庞大而恐怖的项目。6 万人在这条 200 英里的铁路上工作过。他们修建了 99 座桥梁，但这个项目吞噬了无数生命，因为痢疾、
disorderly house in London, and he was accused of paying 800 pounds a month to have a supply of girls in their very early teens. He's a bad man. I think we can conclude that King Leopold II was a very bad man. Now, all of his spending, of course, reflects his big earnings from rubber. It's really hard for us to know how much money he made from all this rubber. But I mentioned one concession company, Anglo-Belgian India Rubber. They made a profit on their rubber of more than 700% and their stock price rose 30 times in four years after they started investing in rubber.
黄热病、天花等等。他们不得不从西非引进工人。他们从香港和澳门引进了数百名中国劳工。这些人往往是在欺骗下被带到这里的。他们被铁链锁在一起。如果他们步履蹒跚，就会被鞭打。不断发生叛乱。死亡人数无法
So I think it's a fair assumption that Leopold is making tens of millions, maybe more, an enormous, in today's money, an enormous, enormous sum of money. And things are only going to get better for him. His railway, by the time he turned 60, his railway is finally nearing completion. It has been a gigantic and a hideous project. 60,000 people have worked on this 200 mile railway. They've built 99 bridges, but the project has eaten people because of dysentery, because
估计，官方数字称有 1800 名非洲人和亚洲人死亡，但实际数字可能要大得多。有些历史学家认为，可能每个月都有数百人死去。不过重申一下，这是渐进式的残酷，因为目标是为了他们自己的长远利益，因为从长远来看，他们以后就不需要背东西上山了，因为会有火车。没错。这全都是为了仁慈。后来有人说，铁路上的每一根枕木——那是美国人对 tie 的称呼，也就是铺在铁轨之间的木条——那每一根木条都代价了一条非洲人的生命。我不
of yellow fever, smallpox, and so on. They've had to bring in workers from West Africa. They've brought in hundreds of Chinese laborers from Hong Kong and Macau. These people have been brought often under false pretenses. They're chained together. They're flogged if they falter. There are constant rebellions. The death toll is impossible to
认为这是一种巨大的夸张。所以利奥波德心想，好吧，当铁路建成时，我可以带着我所有的钱去作更大的梦了。你知道的，也许我们可以把铁路推进到尼罗河流域。我们可以修建一条通往苏丹和埃及的铁路。他开始向英国首相格莱斯顿试探风声。你对把乌干达卖给我感兴趣吗？他对他的朝臣说，你知道的，比利时是一个蒸蒸日上的国家，西班牙、葡萄牙、令人讨厌的荷兰人，你知道的，他们都在衰落。我们可以进军他们的殖民地，实际上，你知道的，我们应该眼光放远，我们应该
estimate the official figures say 1800 Africans and Asians died, but it could be far greater. There are some historians who think maybe hundreds were dying every single month. Just to reiterate though, this is progressive brutality because the goal is for their own benefit because in the long run, they won't then have to carry stuff up because there'll be a train. Exactly. It's all about the kindness. It was said afterwards that every single sleeper on the railway, that's what Americans call the tie, which is the wooden slat that basically goes between the rails, that every single one of those planks cost one African life. And I don't
做更大的梦。所以，在刚果，他是一个垄断者，但他希望将这种垄断扩展到其他领域。是的。现在出现了第一缕批评的微光。真正的第一个批评者实际上是一个名叫乔治·华盛顿·威廉姆斯的非裔美国传教士。他去刚果是为了拯救灵魂。嗯，他是个了不起的人，不是吗？
think that's such a tremendous exaggeration. So Leopold, he thinks, well, when the railway is done, I can dream bigger with all my money. You know, we can push maybe the railway up to the valley of the Nile. We can have a railway that goes up to the Sudan and to Egypt. He starts putting feelers out to Gladstone, the British prime minister. Would you be interested in selling me Uganda? And he says to his courtiers, you know, Belgium is an up and coming country, Spain, Portugal, the hated Dutch, you know, they're decadent. We can move in on their colonies actually, you know, we should be thinking big, we should
是的，一个不可思议的人。他在墨西哥与马克西米利安作战，并在大平原上与水牛士兵并肩作战。我没记错的话，他去了布鲁塞尔，并且成为了布鲁塞尔的红人，因为他是黑人。是的。但我的意思是，他受到布鲁塞尔内部的人道主义、慈善、基督教、进步势力的热烈欢迎。作为黑人奴隶的代表，因为他实际上生来自由，但我的意思是，有一种废除黑人奴隶制的巨大热情浪潮。作为其中的一部分，
dream bigger. So in the Congo, he's a monopolist, but he wants to expand that monopoly into other fields. Yes. Now there are the first glimmers of criticism. The very first critic really is an African American missionary called George Washington Williams. He went to the Congo to try to save souls. Well, he's an amazing man, isn't he?
他去见利奥波德，利奥波德说：“我在刚果所做的一切都是出于对贫苦非洲人的基督徒责任。我并不希望拿回我所花费的所有资金中的哪怕一个法郎。”是的。太无耻了。这就是我认为它与纳粹不同的地方，纳粹并没有假装，你知道的，他们并没有在镇上把黑人传教士奉为上宾，并说他们只关心非洲人的生命，其实他们并不关心。我的意思是，这种虚伪以及残酷同样令人震惊和瞩目。没错。
Yeah, an incredible man. He fought against Maximilian in Mexico and with the Buffalo soldiers on the Great Plains. And am I not right that he goes to Brussels and it's kind of the toast of Brussels because he's black. Yes. But I mean, he's kind of toasted by humanitarian, charitable, Christian, progressive elements within Brussels. And it's as a representative of black slaves who, because he's actually born free, but I mean, there's a kind of this great tide of enthusiasm for abolishing black slavery. And as part of that,
而这家伙，乔治·华盛顿·威廉姆斯，对吧，他和利奥波德开了会，然后他去了刚果，深入内地，心想：什么鬼？这太可怕了。这是一个彻头彻尾的骗局。他发表了一封公开信，他说，你知道的，这简直令人难以置信。比如公安部队已经失控了，他们在杀害所有人。你陛下的政府大规模、零售式地从事奴隶贸易。它买卖和偷窃奴隶。
he goes to see Leopold and Leopold says, what I do in the Congo is done as a Christian duty to the poor African. And I do not wish to have one Frank back of all the money I have expended. Yeah. Shameless. And this is where I think it's different to the Nazis is that the Nazis are not pretending, you know, they're not kind of lording black missionaries in their town and say that they care only for the lives of Africans and they don't. I mean, it's the hypocrisy of it as well as the brutality that is so astonishing and striking. Exactly.
这就是他使用“反人类罪”这个词的地方吗？我想是的。现在利奥波德组织了一场大规模的媒体反击战，说这家伙是在博取眼球。他疯了。不幸的是，乔治·华盛顿·威廉姆斯几个月后就因结核病去世了。但这只是利奥波德精心建造的大厦上的第一道微小裂缝，而且还有更多裂缝。所以在 1896 年，另一位瑞典传教士在伦敦的听众面前说，公安部队正在收集人类的手。
And this bloke, George Washington Williams, right, he's had this meeting with Leopold, and he goes to the conga, he goes up into the interior and he's like, what? This is awful. This is a complete con on a fraud. And he publishes an open letter and he says, you know, this is unbelievable. Like the forced public are out of control, they're killing everybody. Your majesty's government is engaged in the slave trade wholesale and retail. It buys and sells and steals slaves.
还有一个更大的恐慌，这本身就说明了问题。最大的恐慌是公安部队绞死了一个名叫查尔斯·斯托克斯的爱尔兰象牙商人，因为他们说抓到他向阿拉伯奴隶贩子出售武器，他们竟然绞死了一个白人，这非常令人震惊。欧洲报纸开始说，好吧，等等。如果他们可以肆无忌惮地绞死一个白人，如果他们就是这样行事的，那他们对非洲人会做些什么呢？所以事实上，利奥波德再次非常狡猾地处理了这件事。他成立了一个虚假的土著保护委员会，董事会里有传教士。他说他们会调查此事。我的意思是，他们实际上从未真正
And is that where he uses the phrase crimes against humanity? I think he does. Yes. And now Leopold organizes a massive press counterattack, says this guy's intention seeker. He's mad. And unfortunately for George Washington Williams, he dies of tuberculosis just months later. But this is the very first little dent in the edifice that Leopold has very carefully constructed and there are more. So in 1896 another missionary of Swede tells an audience in London that the Force public are collecting human hands.
去过刚果。他们甚至没有开过一次像样的会议，但他们发布了一份报告，太棒了，一切都解决了，你知道的，必要的改革已经进行了。所以那时和现在一样，如果你遇到了问题，就成立一个委员会。成立一个委员会，是的。1897 年，利奥波德可以说是达到了他的巅峰。世界博览会在布鲁塞尔开幕。这里建造并装饰了两个融合了当时新艺术运动风格的大型场所。其中一个完全献给了刚果自由邦。里面有填充的
There's an even bigger scare and this tells its own story. The biggest scare of all the force public hanged an Irish ivory trader called Charles Stokes because they said they'd caught him selling arms to Arab slave dealers and the fact that they had hanged a white man, very shocking. And the European papers start to say, well, hold on. If they would hang a white man with impunity, what are they doing to the Africans if that's how they behave? So actually, Leopold deals with this again, very cunning. He sets up a fake commission for the protection of the natives with missionaries on this board. And he says they'll look into this. I mean, they never actually really
动物、咖啡、巧克力和烟草、装饰品、木制品以及所有这些东西。但重头戏是 267 名人类，他们被像动物园里的动物一样展放在特制的村庄里。甚至还有一个牌子，牌子上写着“黑人由组委会喂养”，因为人们给他们糖果，向他们扔糖果，这让他们生病了。这在当时非常受欢迎。所以在 1889 年巴黎世博会上建造了埃菲尔铁塔，我认为那是为了纪念攻占巴士底狱而举办的，对吧？是的。
traveled to the Congo. They don't really have a proper meeting, but they issue a report, brilliant, all sorted, you know, necessary reforms have been made. So then as now, if you've got a problem, set up a commission. Set up a commission, yeah. In 1897, Leopold arguably reached his apogee. A World's Fair opened in Brussels. There were two great sites built and decorated in the Art Nouveau style of the day. One of them was completely devoted to the Congo Free State. There were stuffed
所以，你知道的，自由、平等、博爱。他们有人类动物园，里面有来自非洲的人。我去过那里，看过那个遗址。它在一个树林里，一个非常阴森的地方，而人们对此完全视为理所当然。有百万人去了这里，去布鲁塞尔看这个展览，我们没有任何迹象表明他们除了认为这绝对精彩之外还想过别的什么。他们太喜欢了。当非洲人最终被送回刚果时，一家报纸说，比利时的灵魂跟随他们，并像朱庇特的盾牌一样保护着他们。
animals, there was coffee and chocolate and tobacco, there were ornaments and woodwork and all this stuff. But the highlight was 267 human beings that were exhibited in specially built villages like animals in the zoo. There was even a sign, the blacks are fed by the organizing committee, said the sign, because people were giving them sweets, throwing sweets to them, which was making them ill. This was very popular at the time. So the 1889 World Fair that they had in Paris that built the Eiffel Tower, which was staged, I think, wasn't it to mark the storming of the Bastille? Yes.
愿我们永远这样向世界展示人道主义的榜样。这种沾沾自喜和某种正义感，简直爆表。所以利奥波德，有什么会出错呢？他有了殖民地，有了橡胶。他有了钱。你知道的，一切看起来都好极了。没有什么能破坏它，不是吗？因为正是在这个时候，安特卫普码头上一个年轻的职员——卸载橡胶的地方——
So, you know, liberty, equality, fraternity. And they had, they had human zoos with people from Africa. And I've been and seen the site. It's in a kind of wood, very sinister location and people just taking it completely for granted. A million people went to this, went to see this exhibition in Brussels and we have no indication that any of them thought anything but that it was absolutely brilliant. They loved it. And when the Africans were finally taken home to the Congo, one newspaper said, the soul of Belgium follows them and like the shield of Jupiter protects them.
开始对这门生意产生疑问。他看到所有这些橡胶和象牙被卸下来，他觉得这很奇怪，因为它们并没有真正显示在公司的账目里，就像有人在暗中吃回扣。这位年轻的船务职员同样无法理解的是，如果我们运进所有这些橡胶和象牙，我们是用什么来支付的？刚果人民得到了什么回报？当他深入调查时，他发现了一件让他真正震惊的事情，因为运回刚果的船上并没有装满贸易货物。
May we always thus show the world an example of humanity. The smugness and the sort of right sense of righteousness, um, off the scale. So Leopold, what could possibly go wrong? He's got his colonies, got his rubber. He's got his money. You know, everything looks great. Nothing could, could spoil it or could it? Because it's about this time that a young clerk on the docks at Antwerp where the rubber is
它们装载的完全是贸易货物，它们装载的完全是步枪和弹药。正是在那个时候，这个年轻人，脑子里灵光一现。正如他后来所说的那样，他说，偶然发现一桩谋杀案已经够糟的了，但我偶然发现了一个以国王为头目的谋杀犯秘密结社。以国王为头目的谋杀犯秘密结社。这个年轻人的名字叫埃德蒙·迪恩·莫雷尔（Edmund Dene Morel）。正如我们下周将发现的那样，他将改变世界。所以我们下周会听到关于这个的故事。但是，如果你是“动荡历史俱乐部”（Restless History Club）的会员，你当然可以听到他的故事以及他发起的非凡运动
being unloaded begins to wander about the trade. He sees all this rubber and ivory being unloaded and he thinks it's weird because it's not really showing up in the company's accounts like somebody is skimming off the top. What he also can't understand this young shipping clerk, if we're getting all this rubber and ivory in, what are we paying for it with? What are the people of the Congo getting back? And when he looks into it, he finds something that really shocks him because the ships that are going back to the Congo are not being loaded with trade goods.
正在卸货的货物开始四处查看。他看到所有这些橡胶和象牙正在卸货，他觉得这很奇怪，因为它们并没有真正出现在公司的账目中，就像有人在从中捞取油水一样。这位年轻的船运职员同样无法理解的是，如果我们运进这么多的橡胶和象牙，我们是用什么来支付的？刚果的人民得到了什么回报？当他深入调查时，他发现了一些让他极为震惊的事情：开往刚果的船只上装载的并不是贸易货物。
They're being loaded exclusively trade goods, they are being loaded exclusively with rifles and ammunition. And it's at that point that this young bloke, the light bulb goes off. And as he later puts it, he said, it was bad enough to stumble upon a murder, but I had stumbled upon a secret society of murderers with a king for a ringleader. a secret society of murderers with a king for a ringleader. And this young man's name was Edmund Dean Morell. And as we'll find out next week, he is going to change the world. So we will be hearing about that next week. But if you are a member of the Restless History Club, you can of course hear his story and the extraordinary campaign that he launches
它们装载的完全不是贸易货物，它们装载的全部都是步枪和弹药。正是在那个时候，这个年轻的小伙子脑子里灵光一现。正如他后来所描述的那样，他说：“偶然撞见一桩谋杀案已经够糟糕的了，但我竟然撞进了一个以国王为首脑的谋杀犯秘密团伙。”这个年轻人的名字叫埃德蒙·迪恩·莫雷尔（Edmund Dean Morell）。正如我们下周将要了解的那样，他将改变世界。所以我们下周会听到相关内容。但如果你是“不安分历史俱乐部”（Restless History Club）的会员，你当然可以提前听到他的故事以及他所发起的非凡运动
against Leopold and what he's getting up to in the Congo right now. And if you're not a member, you can sign up at therestishistory.com. And for everyone else, we will be back on Monday with the next chapter in this terrifying story. Goodbye. Goodbye. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对抗利奥波德以及他目前在刚果的所作所为。如果你还不是会员，可以在therestishistory.com注册。对于其他所有人，我们将在周一带着这个可怕故事的下一章节回归。再见。再见。音乐 本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。